dogs yeah I like dark since I gotta stay
here this is called what dash dog that's
public fights I do you play with you
want what it does is it looks at
pictures of dogs and tells you what kind
of dog is here here's a tough on your
kitty what kind of dog is that yeah it's
a dollar so let's let's use that photo
and you were right let's try another
photo here uh that's actually I have no
idea what that is anybody know what is
that Shepherd I don't Lee said border
collie did you say border collie good
chap and you can actually uh like if I
want to type like I don't know lassie
remember last see that's pricey yoga
more elastic that was a TV dog from the
long time ago and you can search the
wind and find that lassie is a collie
yeah so it's it's not just a set up its
pro kind of cool here's another one
that's still something similar it's
looking at pictures and figuring out
things about the pictures in this case
said looking at dogs and telling the
breed it's looking at people finding the
faces in those photographs were though
where the people are and then telling
you how old they are and it's got some
sample ones it here you can you can see
that it does like across ages and skin
colors and even a two year old as
figures that thing out I can use a I'll
just grab a picture of me from about a
year ago and I'll just tell you that
it's depressing how accurate this is
sometimes what's going on here is that
it's it the reason that knows uh in some
cases more about these pictures than you
and I do like I don't know the names of
all these dogs um is there it's looked
at a lot of pictures of dogs already is
this is a program behind her so software
behind this it's doing machine learning
the idea had a machine learning is that
you take a lot of data and you tell it I
want to figure out how these properties
of that data set are related to these
proper that data set and generally it's
done through kind of an interim
iterative process that it'll take a
guess and it'll see how it's guesswork
and it'll it'll refine its guess and go
through it again machine learning if
you're if you haven't worked with
machine learning it's
really good field to get into especially
you guys in college I think about career
changes you can pretty much add forty
percent of your salary by adding machine
learning or gain of science to your
resume just put that on linkedin
somewhere you'll your email spam will go
up exponentially well a problem what are
the problems Xin learning is that it's
hard it takes it takes a lot of data it
takes a lot of compute power and it
usually takes a lot of time and most of
us don't have any of those things but
Microsoft does and Microsoft has our
cloud compute platform I actually worked
for Microsoft my name is david i am a
technical evangelist that's my title for
Microsoft and my job is to learn cool
technologies and teach them deal we've
got in Azure in our cloud platform
Microsoft Azure we've got some nice
tools that make it more accessible and
easier to build machine learning
solutions but you still have to know the
principles of machine learning in order
to use those tools so there is a barrier
to enter a gift I would not discourage
you from wearing that but in the
meantime even if you don't know anything
about machine learning you can take
advantage of the machine learning this
thing on the back end of these services
because these are just these websites
are just calling web services behind
them and those web service are taking
advantage of the flub all this machine
learning all this data crunching looking
at thousands hundreds of thousands of
pictures of dogs and people and finding
the ages and the breeze those dogs and
saying okay well a collie has ears that
are shaped like this and hair that's
this long i know is shaped like that and
so on and it's got a good idea of what
the properties of the picture are
relative to what the breed of dog is or
what the properties of our faces and
what a two-year-old looks like versus a
53-year old man looks on the bike and
these have been exposed to you for use
for free as Microsoft cognitive services
so the take advantage of it you go to
microsoft.com / cognitive dash services
which rolls off the tongue and usually
called project oxford before it was in
beta here's the thing about microsoft we
do a lot of things really well but
naming products is not one of them it's
we always have really good beta names
for products
project Oxford sounds really good fact
my original slide deck had jokes about
the Oxford comma in it in cognitive
services but that's what it's called
cognitive services what's called go
right here and you can sign up for free
if you click on right get started for
free you will need what we call a
Microsoft account these colors live
account so if you had outlook.com email
address or a live com email address or
even feel about gmail or a UIC email
address you can you could associate that
with Microsoft account and sign in and
then you can use all these categories of
services there's some provision for
speech for natural language processing
searching the web for doing knowledge
search show to make sure I'm sign in
here to see I'm not usually I'm already
signed in because i'm using some other
service email or onedrive something like
that i'm already signed so yeah it looks
like it just took my credentials right
away and these the ones that i've signed
up for and i say that they're free when
i say they're free i mean that there's a
certain number of times per month and a
certain time number of times per minute
that you can call these services and
that's being tracked right here for each
one of the services of for example for
the face service i click on show quarter
usually takes a lot of calculate this
it'll tell me that i started this on
january fifth so probably the fifth of
each month this thing will reset and I
get what I got thirty thousand
transactions that's plenty to learn it
to build some sample applications to
publish them if you wanted to build a
business around this where you're going
to build a new Facebook and it's going
to have these services behind it then
thirty thousand might not be enough
hopefully be charging for it that time
and then you can buy more when you buy
more you actually deploy it to Azure and
Azure is a highly scalable platform so
you get all the power of azure here uh
this is gonna spend forever I guess but
it would tell me probably all 30,000 I
don't think i've used it lets the 27th
they're probably is a few of them so
probably like twenty nine thousand and
nine hundred and something are left for
that and the way that it knows that it's
me is because every time i call the
service i have to pass one of these two
keys here the reason there's two of them
is because it's possible that somebody
might see one of those keys like i might
accidentally show it to you and you
might look at it really quickly or it
might be recorded by this camera here so
by the time this recording is really
celtic strike that key regenerate what
I'm regenerate I would use the other key
so don't don't don't look when I showed
that key that's a secret you could you
could for example call that 30,000 at
one time next time I do the demo it
wouldn't work for me all right i guess
it's spinning forever doesn't like me
all right so what are these are these
are web services how do I use them but
come down here to the api's you'll see
you're under vision there's computer
vision and emotion and face and video to
do analysis of images analysis of video
analysis it'll tell you things like
what's in the picture what are some of
the what's a reasonable caption for the
picture what are the faces in there
where is the eyes where's the nose or
the mouth is he wearing glasses there
are their facial hair is that are they
smiling are they happy I they said are
they angry um same thing in videos
there's a speech recognition that it can
do you can tell whether or not it's me
speaking you can match a voice with a
set of known voices you can do up your
login like that you can do
authentication say being in my
application speak this phrase and it
would match it to the the known users
voice and say that doesn't sound like
you denied all sorts of thing we're
gonna focus mostly on the vision this
why I only have about 45 minutes so I'm
going to cover just that I want to do
this let's see let's dive into the
computer vision right here then I have
all kinds of links in the first thing is
I really love this this is a demo of
what's happening behind the scenes so in
the applications we saw somebody built a
website on top of that and had some nice
pretty pictures but really what's coming
back is JSON and JSON is just a standard
format for sending and receiving data
across the Internet it's nice and terse
it's really small compact so it works
really well across the Internet and the
data that's in that JSON package that
comes back from this particular API this
particular web service call it is this
data there's a description so it'll look
at a picture and here we got some sample
pictures and description here and this
one is a man swimming in a pool of water
so it put a pretty good job of figuring
out what that picture is there are some
keyword tags in here like water and
sport swimming pool this information
about that type of image it is the JPEG
the size of it whether it's not it's
clipart whether that's a line drawing
but it's black and white it
adult content or is racy content these
are kind of interesting because they are
they're not it's not really there is a
true false here but there's also a score
so it's fifteen percent sure that it's a
that it's adult content and it's that
it's probably not adult content it
probably not zero because he meant as a
shirt off but this is nice this will be
nice thing to save them an application
that you want to allow people to upload
their own images and then show them to
the public well that's there's some risk
involved in that and if you do that you
probably want to make sure that they're
not uploading dirty pictures and so this
would be a good way to analyze those
pictures automatically and say you know
what if that score gets above a
30-percent point three I better have a
human being look at this up critic you
separate q don't publish it till
somebody that's it make sure that it is
okay i actually don't know what the
difference is between racy and adults I
think they're similar but yeah things
about the color of the image all sorts
of things here I can select one of these
here like this let me grab all here's a
line art drawing like a lion lion are
driving so in that case is the black and
white image is true it's definitely not
adult content and it's a line drawing
and it's clipart as well and says here
what is to say a close up of two
giraffes directory so it's not perfect
so it's trying to figure it out so it
does better with photographs done with
images all right let's uh let's talk
about from the standpoint of developers
because a lot of people who are
developers room writing in writing in
Python mostly I imagine since that's in
the title the conference and here's the
real beauty of it yeah it's a it's a
tool from Microsoft but you don't have
to use anything at all Microsoft where
later in order to use this it's just a
web service it is a rest webservice you
can hit it with the post verb you can
post to a URI you send some information
in the header you since I'm appreciative
body you get back some JSON that any
language can do that python could
certainly be men and I go down to the
documentation here I'll see all sorts of
information about how to use this thing
so I come down to my vision API let me
grab the one we're just looking at
analyze image and there's information
just kind of text about how to use this
end
how it works if I want to know more
about how to call it then I can select I
can go to the API reference right here
and then here it'll tell me exactly how
i'm going to call this in so in this are
the here's the you are it's an HTTP
method how many here work with the rest
before looks like about half the room
that so the idea behind rest is let me
use the power of HTTP to manage some
resource on the back end in this case
the resources information about these
images so all i have to do is make a
rest a web service call to a uri like it
sends some data to that as parameters
and i can receive some data back and
it's just like calling any other
function inside of your application
except you're calling it over the
internet using standards so this case
the uri i'm going to hit is this one
right here htps coleman whack whack api
that project oxford yeah that's the old
better name of this set of services /
vision / v 1.0 that's all there is right
now / analyze and this optional query
string parameters can add to that i'll
hit that with the post verb and the
parameters that i can pass are in the
query string i can pass the visual
features if i want to return the
categories or the tag in the description
i can tell it to return as much as I
want the less i put in here for smaller
the data package the faster they'll be
but the more i put in here that more
data i'll get back what kind of details
that i want to get back right now the
only detail a lot of celebrities it'll
mash up to see if it's a picture of Tom
Cruise or Katy Perry or where
celebrities and then in the header I'm
going to request the content type and
the content type can be either JSON
which means i'm going to pass some json
in the body or it'll be if i want to
send binary it'll either be a
application octet stream or multi-part
form data depending about how I'm gonna
pass that binary data so i can send the
image itself organs to send json that
here's some json it's just a URL that
points to the image out of a web
somewhere
and then I'll get back a bunch of JSON
that looks kind of like this here's a
sample of data that i would get back
home where is just json you can parse
that out using whatever programming
language you want if you want to see
that in action there's actually a
testing Constance do that let's grab its
testing console and in this case I'll
say that features that one I'll just do
the default you're out i wanta get the
categories back the content type it'll
be JSON that's how i'm going to send the
body a subscription key now I've got to
grab that from here from my account so
my subscription key for the vision API
sometimes that shaped my life I close I
said yeah that's a pro tip totally
computer vision so everybody close your
eyes let's have a copy of that right
there I it's copied and better hide it
and I'll just paste that into here all
right and then the this is a sample
there's the body I'll send this as the
body right here let's grab that and I
want a picture of I don't what's good
let's search for something how about a
picture of bruce springsteen in concert
I guess I'll concert right images let's
see if that works you guys remember
Bruce Benson everybody URL to jpg let's
grab that to see you heavens so I'll
just fix that and this is my web service
call click send and I could get error I
mean I'll get a response code back HTTP
always sends a response code if it's 200
that's code for everything work
everything's okay if it's not 200 there
might have been a problem anything
starts that's 400 as a problem and it'll
give up like its 404 for example means
not found we all type the wrong URL em
so if I put a picture and it doesn't
exist I probably get a 404 back 401
means not authenticated that's a common
one if I type the wrong key and I
probably get a 401 back this is 200 so
came back okay and here's the data it
says a category I only asked for the
category so you give a whole lot of data
back so people show let me let me grab
it different let's see instead of doing
the analyze damage let's do something a
little bit more interesting here and I'm
gonna describe one look at the emotions
1 i'll tell you what rather than doing
that wanted to show you some some code
samples let's do that code that I wrote
that's more fun mother was in Python I
don't have a Python moms
but I don't think it's these purposes
you can see the HTTP call if you can
make a call and Python let me actually
show you that if you want to do some
Python then on here I think it's at our
documentation it actually is a microsoft
com / cognitive services there are
samples on here for calling it in a lot
of different languages so if I under
developers if I grab the documentation
here then I should be able to see for
any one of these things where's my
emotions an interesting one the API
reference and down here at the bottom oh
here we go right here so here's how I
call them that's my favorite item C
sharp but right there's Python right
here there's how you call that Python
import these libraries editors equals
that params equals that got to scroll
down a little bit to see it all and just
a few lines of code in fact they have it
for Python to seven and four three two
so right here you can copy and paste
that into your code and start using this
and of course you want to change the end
of the URL of the image that you're
sending to grab some code that I wrote
here so it's to do they analyze damaged
end off
whenever there's awkward silence I'm
okay with it it's only awkward for you
guys Irina so this is a what is this I
forgotten that well this is a windows
application looks like a uwp application
so in this case actually there's my
subscription can you don't look there it
is I'm going to analyze an image I'm
going to grab it out of a text box and
what I've done actually this is kind of
nice it's some for some languages for
some of the api's we actually have
libraries they can add it as a package
manager in da hedrick and very quickly
add libraries to this nuget package
manager i'm doing that here so that's
kind of nice for a lot of these things
where i can instead of having to make
that right the ace to call myself i can
use this some vision service client
which is definition of that here here's
a vision service client so this is a
library that I've imported I pass in the
subscription tea and now this vision
server vision service client has methods
like analyzed image a sink which
asynchronously I legislators the image i
pass in an image URL I passing a list of
features that i want to get and it will
asynchronously return a result and that
result has things like a description
which has a number of captions it also
has a number of tags and then I just go
as a racy score so this one here what
I'm doing is I'm looking to display on
screen a description a bunch of tags and
then I had a thing here that if the racy
score is above point three then I have
an image that says oh that's shocking
don't don't show that one but let me
shut it so even though i'm using this
library under the hood all that library
is doing is it's calling out to that web
service it's just a wrapper for that
it's nice to use that because then i get
strongly typed data get intellisense in
my ide things like that so analyze this
image here and i'll call that web
service i get a white cat looking the
birds the caption all these keywords
here i bet will drop down list here and
it says
there there's my list by racing it's a
crazy Annalise image and I'll get a
caption and some tags and this one
because it's above point three I get da
shocking it's racing and this one here
let's this is I did this actually
demonstration I went down to Disney they
had an internal conference and just
before that if I gotta suck up the
Disney because so I added this because
Disney own star wars now and it did this
analyzed image on that one and I thought
the caption decisions mark hamill it
recognized mark holding a bat so it is
recognized mark but didn't recognize the
lightsaber thought that was interesting
and not at all erasing that's cool all
right let me grab a couple here talking
that show them all the motions dim let's
do that one motions demo I like this one
in this case there's an API that will
not only look at the picture but it'll
find where all the faces are and it'll
tell you whether they're happy sad angry
surprising there's like eight emotions
and it doesn't it what it does it gives
a score for each one square between zero
and one and so if it's extremely happy
it'll give you a hundred percent
happiness score and zero percent
everything else but usually our emotions
are more complex than that so in this
case here I've got again I'm using the
library for this just a wrapper for this
that passing in the key this emotion
service client and what I call that it
has the most service client has a method
called recognized a sink and that will
call the emotion you can call that a web
service under the hood I'll pass in the
URL of an image that I'm going to get
from a drop box and you'll be able to
see the data that comes back it's JSON
but the rest of this is just I'm going
to parse through all that JSON that
comes back and display it all this stuff
here is just grabbing see I get scores
for every face for every face in the
image i gets a set of scores and there's
a scores not anger scores that contempt
scores I've discussed or everything
that's the score between zero and one to
say how angry are there how contemptuous
on how disgusting are so here's one
there's a little girl she looks pretty
angry so if I grab her
emotions it's going to call that and I
get back that I just put down the score
anger is point 93 you know happiness at
this point juzer 00 not happy at all and
I just this I lived through and found
whatever the highest number was anger in
labs on and let's see this is what i
have here this is this was the sad
LeBron I was taken before the playoffs
he's not sad anymore he's very happy and
so he's 91 % sad he was a year ago and
this was taken it works for this is cool
that works for multiple people a whole
bunch of people in here some of the
faces are partly obscured like this
person in the middle here and so I
grabbed the emotions and now I'll get
actually one two three four five six
seven there are nine faces in here
they're all happy they're all smiling so
happiness is the highest score and all
those things and it'll look for these
are three phases with different emotions
so ones neutral ones happy one set and
again just before a bunch of Disney I
wanted to analyze clear responses here I
wanted to analyze kylo Ren because he's
a guy that hides his emotion really well
so no matter what every picture I did
like five pictures of kylo Ren and
everyone on this neutral that's just
like I'm sure he's a fine actor but he
didn't show his range in this movie
that's all I'm saying all right me show
you want to actually cut making raw HTTP
HTTP calls to actually forget I want to
show you one thing so I showed you the
face demo no I didn't show you a victim
all you do that emotions based it i'll
show you this this is a this is in
JavaScript so in here I'll just open
this up in a text editor so here we go
this is um I'm learning some JavaScript
here hope I didn't [ __ ] it's putting my
daughter's right here he's script
there's no JavaScript right here in this
case I'm going to analyze some faces
it'll tell me where so here we go this
is I just um my subscription keys in
another file I grab that I'm going to
get the image you are a lot of a text
box and type it in
default for it here's the web service
URL i'm going to call so this is this is
actually raw calling the the web service
itself i'm really not using any library
except for jQuery jQuery has a nice
syntax for making it an AJAX call so
right here here's what i call it like i
said a post to the web service URL
that's this one API departure Oxford I /
face the face API in the headers I give
it the subscription key the content type
of the application / JSON and the data
the JSON itself will be URL colon
whatever URL i pass to it and then when
it this also was a synchronous in
JavaScript everything is asynchronous so
when it's done it'll it'll look through
the data that comes back and what I do
is I draw a rectangle around the where
the face is so this comes back it tells
me where is the where the corners the
face and where is the eyes and where is
it in mouth and I swear the nose and
things like that so I've got some labels
that I just make visible position where
the highest nose and mouth I let's go
ahead and do that Brown this here oh not
that one sorry while we're an index this
one right here
it was a face here and the code ran
because I've got a URL of a picture of
this fellow right here with a drill I
drew a rectangle around where cognitive
service told me the outline of his face
is where his left eye as was right eye
and its nose and his mouth and so on are
here's the data they came back I just
add came as JSON but I output it's a
little bit easier to read here it's a
55-point five year old male he's only
not smiling very much he has reading
glasses on things like that and I can
change that with any other URL here URL
of give me a name Barack Obama expellers
images cost center one there I Chicago
guy and out of here there he is I
figured out where he was that's kind of
now this one here you'll notice actually
I'm doing something that you probably
shouldn't do and what I what I'm doing
is I am passing when I make this call
right here notice I'm passing the
subscription key from a client my web
browser out to a server that's a
security risk so this is for demo
purposes I wouldn't recommend because
somebody could be sniffing packets along
there somewhere and they could read your
subscription key or maybe maybe steal it
maybe change it whatever it whenever you
pass keys it's probably a good idea not
to pass them directly from JavaScript or
from a client application what I like to
do is this right here what I like to do
is create my own web service I've done
that here it's a web service that does
nothing at all except call the cognitive
services web service and but before does
it it reads the API from some secure
straight reads that key from us to cure
store this is exactly the same thing
where instead of calling kind of some
services directly I javascript is
calling my web servers this is my web
service and my web service is right here
right here
and it is making the call to cognitive
services so there's the URL there's my
subscription key and pulling it out of a
config file however you secure it you
know you should secure it and then this
thing actually makes a call to cognitive
sources this is a better pattern here
and by the way these are all available
on my github page so if you want to see
any this code I know I'm going really
fast for here to them we have 45 minutes
but it's all available at github.com /
my name I'll put the slide up at the end
with that and so the cognitive service
demos are all available there let's 15
minutes left it shook everything I could
run this thing run what the heck it's
really the same demo we saw before
exactly the same thing will happen it'll
show a picture of a face I'll draw a
rectangle around it and it'll identify
the eyes nose and mouth but it's going
through proxy it's going through some
other service right here so there it is
right there and they're all right here
somewhere did this because I thought it
was interesting that it works that API
works even if the person's wearing
sunglasses still could figure out where
their eyes nose mouth are even if their
head is tilted it's actually pretty good
little one of the things that you can't
have a turn back return to you is the
tilt of the head so if you want to
manipulate this image in some way you
can do that let me show you the text
sorry the the OCR optical character and
let's have a cool so in optical
character recognition it'll look at a
picture of text and they'll tell you
what that text is and the way it returns
it is is a bunch of a race there's like
a ray of text areas so you may have a
picture that has some text over here and
some text over there it'll send an array
of those and within each text area it'll
be an array of lines and within each
line they'll be an array of work
and the reason they do that is because
that way if you wanted to and you wanted
to manipulate that you want to say let's
replace the third word and the seventh
line of text area to then you could do
that and so that's what I'm doing here
and this is all from to JavaScript I've
got a URL and select the URL from a
drop-down list so I'll grab that and
I'll show the picture of you are just
using jquery this and then here's my
double to my solution p i got high
tolerance i got change if we generate
them all tonight and here i'm making a
call to this web service so in this case
the URL happens to be a pi/2 I project
Oxford got a I / vision / 1 point 0 and
then I'm gonna pass in headers the
subscription key the content type in the
body I'll pass in this the URL of the
image with the pictures on it when I'm
done it'll return some JSON and I'll
grab how I'll just loop through all
those text areas each with a text area i
looked through all the lines we do the
line home throughout the words in this
case I'm just going to output it as text
I'll just attend where am I hero inside
of a dip that's all so let me run that
thing I don't know why created this
visual studio just done whole thing
notepad
so here the first one here this is a
poem by Robert Frost two roads diverged
in a yellow wood oh I could get texting
a call that service and it did pretty
view at the road not to worry it's a
tebow instead of two so the quality of
the text makes a difference here but
almost rest of the thing is all good let
me grab a this one's a little bit poorer
quality text but it's still there really
good of this lana fellow palm down at
the bottom I've got some hard over this
one is a text on dark paper with some
splotches on it and I'm mark ' dia to
figure that out we're on a little
promontory it stood isolated and this
one here not only has dark paper with
some texture to it but also its Old
English and I'm looking like my mistress
eyes are nothing but it's not mistress
is the the S is stylized like we make F
style back in the day back in
Shakespeare's day I used to make guesses
like that well it read it as read it as
my mistress eyes and then the big letter
M didn't know what do with that so I put
that on a separate line so your quality
of your reading will be directly
proportional to quality of the image
that you have all right and then one
image one more thing or I'll show you
two more demos I'll show you the text to
speech to let me see if that microphone
is moving I'm sorry speech to text so
it's kind of what this does is that as i
as i call this api use a library for
this one what does it call the api then
it listens to everything I'm saying and
there's an event that fire but know that
the fires every time it detects short
pause between words and I can tap into
that event to say every time i text a
certain word make a call to the web
service get back what it thinks I've
said so far and when I dicks a long
between the words is another event that
fires this says okay he's done speaking
let's end the program and what will
happen is that it'll take a guess as I'm
speaking as to what the words
our but it gets further along with a
sentence it will realize Oh or number
three I guess from doesn't really make
sense in this context I better change it
and hopefully you'll be able to see that
so if I rim this thing here and start
recording stick with the poetry part of
this let's say whose woods are these I
think I know his house is in the village
though he will not see me standing here
to watch his woods fill up with snow so
this is another rubber another robbery I
think you saw that it would went back
and change words as it found that
ultimately it got most of it right but
not the first time it was an iterative
process last one we do is one just a
cute little one I did that use several
these emotions right or someone several
of these api's I didn't show you the
thumbnail API that really glad to see it
somebody likely is really simple you
would think that the thumbnails will be
easy if you have a picture and you want
to turn into the thumbnail but to shrink
it down but it's really not that simple
what if you want to turn a square
picture into a rectangle or a portrait
into a landscape you you want to keep
the main subject in the frame still and
so what kind of services does is it will
it'll remember it will figure out what
the main part of the picture is and it
will it'll keep that in as it changes
the size and shape of it and so this one
here all I did with a little bit show
you the code here there's my
subscription key i'm using this library
the vision service client library it i
do this before I use a different method
of this time i use get thumbnail a sink
it returns a thumbnail and then all i do
is i just download that thumbnail is a
series of bytes I save it a test folder
and I you know I call it I pass in my
original picture my original picture is
this picture I wasn't Stockholm last
year's a picture of Stockholm Harbor and
so what I'm done all I do is I just
display the original picture and the
thumbnail so there's the original
picture and there's the thumbnail that's
all it's doing
and I'd show you that because I wanted
to show you the one that I created it
combines a lot of these together so in
this one I call it emotions in motion
here we go if I grab this one it has
some thumbnail images in it it has some
facial amount recognition and it has
some emotion recognition I'm doing a lot
of those things and actually you know
this is online others emotions in motion
the quarter to a drink that a shirt as
your web sites that i hope i spelled
right
well the settlements left
stratus you also this is a website
believe it or not this website doesn't
you hit that offer and where the eye is
works is if you if it hasn't hit for a
while it just goes to sleep everything
goes out of memory so the first person
that hits it pays that penalty so you
see there's some thumbnails up here a
pictures of this good-looking guy here
and that of an error message I'm not
sure why that's true so i won't i
probably won't be able to do the patrol
out fire and i don't know my eris so i
won't be able to show you this one here
key back because it's pretty much the
greatest app ever written I will point
you I'm gonna point you to a couple of
resources here because I'm gonna save
five minutes for question then only have
six nights left so if i go to hear I
were not my powerpoint are you guys
disappointed that I didn't have a
PowerPoint up at this point I do have
like this right here and oh there's my
there's my oxford shirt Oxford comma
jokes but that's not actually i want to
show you here first i want to show you
the here's the the Python for one of
these calls that's in Python 2 7's in
package I think it's relevant to this
audience here if you know how to make a
web service call this should be easy for
you this is very simple stop it for
doing it in just about any language
here's um if you go to this URL right
here you'll see a bunch of resources
that I've written and grab those so
you'll see blog posts that I've written
you'll see a link to my github
repository is here I did some screencaps
the screencasts are pretty much a lot of
a demos that you've seen today down here
are some blog posts i was on a podcast
recently talking about this very topic
here i wrote some hands-on labs if you
want to go up towards step-by-step
there's some probably about two hours
worth of material in there the slides
are in there although the one slide with
the python code is not i just added that
last night so this is this is a good
starting point for any resource right
here and then also the other place you
want to know is microsoft
coms you can hit the spell every night /
cognitive services to get started out
here so those are the links that you
want to see and then these are the demos
that I showed you what dog got that how
old I met um and that is my presentation
I thank you very much and I will stick
around for questions thank you alright
then about five minutes depression or
not absolute yes okay so the question
was what if I built my own machine
learning model can I get that hooked
into cognitive services and the answer
is the the cognitive service is kind of
a closed system do you basically get
what you what you get so that's
abstracted away from you so not in that
case however if you're using the machine
learning and Azure there is a button
down at the bottom which allows you to
publish your findings as a web service
essentially with one collect so you can
publish something similar to cognitive
services using your own data your own
apple and algorithms then it goes yeah
so the question is do we have reference
to any of the models that the cognitive
services team is using there on the
Congress recite I didn't see anything
published on that however they I think
they have a blog and they were revealing
some of the stuff that they're doing the
edger team and the Commerce urgency
would really open about the kind of
research that they're doing so I'm not
sure how detailed that is but you could
explore them there is some stuff but I
don't how much Yeah right here okay
so the question is is there a
drag-and-drop interface as your machine
money is that ok so as your mission I
didn't talk much about Azure machine
learning and the edge of machine
learning is a way for you create your
own machine learning solutions it is a
visual interface where you can drag and
drop objects onto a design surface and
it saves you the trouble of writing a
lot of code to do things like get my
data from this source or split it up
that way or set default values so that
part is just made a lot easy for it
takes care of a lot of plumbing code for
you and then you can write Python code
in that you can right-click and wash up
what's the notebook Jupiter you can
write Python code inside so if you want
to use this inside of some of your
machinery absolutely yeah one of the
shapes is call a webservice and you
could call webster so you can take your
data and have a steps for dinner you can
put anything that can call a webservice
can call this so doesn't matter if it's
a mobile app you could writing iphone
apps to be writing console apps you can
do writing web page of the Java store
machine learning yeah
well I don't know recognizing like brand
logos I'm sure are you let's test that
the question was does a wouldn't
recognize something like the Nike logo
and it was his shoes for example like
the type of shoes I don't really know
specialist can I train it nog myself and
the answer is no this abstract sawey a
lot of that work for you and there's
always a trade-off between abstraction
which gives you less control but less
work and then you know getting down in
the weeds and you get more control but
then you have to do all the work
yourself so ml studios where you want to
go for something like that all right
next group is coming out I will stick
around for any more questions I hope I
really love the questions here because
the whole point of this talk is to get
your mind thinking about hey I could use
that on my next project and I hope
that's happened here today so thank you
so much i'll be looking the better after
i pack up anyways i'm very happy too
proud